à son tour laurent fabius entre dans la
course à l'investiture du ps pour
l'élection présidentielle rejoignant
ainsi 2000 strauss kahn et ségolène
royal reste encore à connaître la
décision de jack lang l'ancien premier
ministre s'est démarqué de la favorite
des sondages se présentant comme le
candidat du pouvoir d'achat un
discours-programme combatif prononcé
dans le gers
rosine sur laurent fabius se concentre
sur son discours qu'il peaufine cette
candidature il en rêve depuis si
longtemps pourtant prg avant le 21 avril
2002 liddell avait effleuré de quitter
la politique
persuadé que lionel jospin l'emporterait
réseau soir du premier tour les rêves de
jospin s'écroulait ceux de faible us
commencé aujourd'hui dans le gers
une fois de plus stimulée par le retrait
de l'ancien premier ministre laurent
fabius se lance dans la bataille
chers amis chers camarades j'ai décidé
si les militants socialistes le veulent
d'être candidat à la présidence de la
république il vrai disque au programme
de 40 minutes l'ancien social libéral
devenu le fou socialiste des socialistes
s'est dit le candidat des gens modestes
il promet des réformes profondes et
croit en son destin
j'ai confiance parce que je me suis
préparé pour cette tâche j'ai confiance
parce que je sais que la majorité des
français en particulier les jeunes ne
veulent pas d'une société brutale et
précaires que leur prépare monsieur
sarkozy mais qu'ils veulent comme nous
une france porte une france sus une
france sur une france solidaire une
chance forts parce que soliveres innues
laurent fabius qui veut fort que la rose
socialiste que refleurit entre ses mains
un rêve encore lointain ségolène royal
toujours reine des sondages caracole en
tête chez les sympathisants socialistes
avec 49 % contre 6 % pour laurent fabius
comme disait jean pierre raffarin en son
temps la pente est rude